it sure has been a rollercoaster over
the past few days with Sony and Disney
trying to work out a deal for spider-man
to stay in the MCU how's it going
everybody it's Warren and we all love
Tom Holland as spider-man he was
specifically casted for the MCU by Kevin
Feige and Amy Pascal but of course we
know that Marvel once upon a time sold
the rights to spider-man to Sony and
although Marvel and Disney had a deal
with Sony for spider-man to be able to
appear in the MCU it looks like that
deal has come to an end for whatever
reason it may be that Marvel and Disney
and Sony could not come to an agreement
Kevin Feige has released an official
statement along with Tom Holland and
Sony as well and as it stands right now
spider-man is no longer going to be in
the MCU sadly and Tom Holland has
released a new official statement about
the situation that I'll break down in
this video real quick if you'd like a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be
sure to subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain I'll be
picking a winner at 500,000 subscribers
we're getting really really close so
like I said spider-man is no longer
going to be in the MCU but we do have
some good news for a while it was
unknown if spider-man 3 was actually
going to still remain a part of the MCU
since Disney and Sony did have an
agreement for spider-man 3 to be in the
MCU and then another question was will
Tom Holland even continue to play
spider-man even though he will no longer
be a part of the MCU because we did find
out that he had the option to either
stay or leave well thanks to an official
statement from Tom Holland in an
interview yesterday we learned a lot
more about what is going to happen with
spider-man 3 and what is going to happen
with Tom Holland playing spider-man at
Keystone Comic Con yesterday in
Philadelphia Tom Holland said it's not
the end of me playing spider-man there's
definitely more to come we sat down with
some of our creatives we pitched fighter
Man 3 which is going to be something
very special it's going to be something
very different I'm just so grateful that
Marvel changed my life and allowed my
dreams to come true and Sony allowing me
to continue living my dreams and he
continued to say it's really exciting
the ideas we have for how we can expand
the spider-man world and bring new
characters into it and crossover with
other people it's really exciting and
it's only going to get bigger and better
from here
which is
great so sadly Tom Hollands comments
confirmed that spider-man three is not
going to be a part of the MCU despite
whatever previous contract Disney and
Sony had now of course there's still
time for Disney and Sony to come to an
agreement before spider-man 3 starts
filming but the good news is it sounds
like Sony is going to do everything they
can to make good spider-man films moving
forward and Tom Holland is still going
to continue to play spider-man which is
great because a lot of people really
love him and it sounds like they have
plans for big crossover events which of
course the first thing that everybody
thinks about is venom venom of course is
also another character that Sony owns
the rights to and that they could use in
a Sony spider-man film and since a
majority of the people really love Tom
Hardy as venom and really love Tom
Holland as spider-man it could make for
a great crossover event for spider-man
vs. venom which could then lead to them
teaming up in another film to go against
carnage
so again sadly spider-man 3 will not
take place in the MCU but it does seem
like Sony has some really good plans for
spider-man moving forward
so hopefully Sony will do a good job and
we can continue to get good spider-man
films but let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
let me know if you think that Sony on
their own can make a good spider-man
film and again don't forget to subscribe
to my channel like the video and comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
to enter my giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU also
don't forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf